estarías maravillado con las cosas que
puedes construir utilizando únicamente
regla y compás una regla te sirve para
dibujar líneas y un compás te sirve para
dibujar círculos con centros donde tú
quieras que estén centrados esos
círculos y de diferente radio ahora aquí
tenemos el equivalente virtual a un
compás oprimo este botón y yo puedo
construir un círculo puedo yo elegir
donde yo quiera centrar ese círculo y
puedo cambiar el radio de ese círculo
así que eso es lo que yo puedo hacer con
la herramienta de compás ahora con la
herramienta de regla yo aquí obtengo un
segmento de línea lo puedo alargar lo
puedo mover puedo poner algún extremo de
ese segmento en algún punto donde yo
quiera puede ser en p por ejemplo y eso
es lo que puedo hacer con las
herramientas de compás y reglas ahora
veamos que se nos pide si se construye
una línea que pase por p y sea tangente
al círculo entonces yo podría decir
ok voy a utilizar la regla voy a mover
esta regla de tal forma que bueno la voy
a acomodar de tal forma que pase por p
y sea tangente a este círculo una línea
tangente tocará el círculo en
exactamente un punto ese punto debe ser
p entonces bueno yo puedo decir más o
menos es ese otra manera de pensar en la
línea tangente es que será perpendicular
al radio entre el punto p y el centro
del círculo ahora bien lo que yo acabo
de dibujar parece parece que es la
tangente parece bastante bien pero no es
tan preciso no sé si es exactamente
perpendicular al radio no sé si está
tocando al círculo en exactamente un
punto entonces usaremos nuestras
herramientas para intentar hacer un
dibujo más preciso así que voy a borrar
esta línea ahora lo primero que haré es
que pese a el punto medio de un segmento
donde el centro de este círculo será uno
de los extremos de ese segmento entonces
agrega un compás y quiero construir un
círculo que tenga el mismo radio que el
círculo original entonces quiero un
círculo original pero este nuevo círculo
lo voy a centrar en el punto p entonces
lo centro en p y esto porque me sirve
bueno pues ahora el diámetro de ese
nuevo círculo será un segmento con
centro en p eso quiere decir que p está
en el punto medio de ese segmento y el
centro de mi círculo original será un
extremo de ese segmento entonces ahora
voy a agregar esta línea que tiene un
extremo en el centro del ciclo original
pasa por p y llega hasta el otro extremo
del círculo nuevo
ahora bien pero ahora ya es el punto
medio de este segmento y si yo puedo
construir un segmento que visite a este
segmento que es el diámetro de ese
círculo que construimos y que ese
segmento tanto vicente como sea
perpendicular a él entonces pasará por p
porque es el punto medio y será
exactamente perpendicular al radio de
este círculo el círculo original
entonces yo quiero un segmento que haga
eso que vi secta y sea perpendicular a
ese segmento que pasaporte para que para
que sea perpendicular al radio del
círculo original entonces veamos cómo
puedo hacer eso voy a construir otro
círculo
este nuevo círculo lo voy a centrar en
el círculo original
pero quiero que este nuevo círculo tenga
un radio distinto un radio mayor
ahí queda bien ahora voy a construir
otro círculo que tenga el mismo radio
que este que acabo de construir los
centro en el en el círculo original en
el centro del círculo original y quiero
que tenga el mismo radio pero este nuevo
círculo lo centraré en ese punto y que
esto interesante de esos dos círculos
con mayor radio bueno pues donde se
intersectan esos dos círculos con mayor
radio esos dos puntos equidistantes
extremos del segmento que pasa por p ya
que ambos círculos tienen el mismo radio
por tanto si estoy sobre ambos
ambos círculos entonces estoy a la misma
distancia de ambos extremos del segmento
del segmento que pasa por p y algo que
crist a ambos extremos de un segmento
estará también en el segmento que vi
secta y es perpendicular a ese segmento
en este caso visitará y será
perpendicular al segmento que pasa por p
así que ambos puntos ambas
intersecciones de estos dos círculos
estarán sobre la bisectriz perpendicular
al segmento que pasa por p y entonces ya
lo podemos dibujar con un extremo en
esta intersección de estos dos círculos
y el otro en la otra intersección de los
dos círculos grandes esos dos puntos
aquí están ambos centros de los círculos
entonces acabo de construir una
bisectriz perpendicular al segmento que
pasa por p y es perpendicular al radio
de nuestro círculo original entonces esa
será nuestra línea tangente porque
estamos pasando por p y es una línea que
es perpendicular al radio desde p al
centro del círculo original por lo tanto
esta es la línea tangente al círculo
original y que pasa por p lo que se nos
pedía entonces bueno puede parecer que
es mucho trabajo pero inténtalo estamos
aquí siendo precisos y si tú quieres
algún día ser por ejemplo arquitecto
bueno debes aprender a hacer estas cosas
debes aprender a hacer este tipo de
dibujos debe ser muy preciso entonces si
quieres ser arquitecto o ingeniero bueno
esto te será muy útil
y antes antes de las computadoras y todo
toda esta nueva tecnología lo que se
hacía era estas construcciones entonces
bueno sería todo y nos vemos